en votre enfant sommeil peut être un
molière le théâtre montansier a lancé
mercredi 21 septembre une activité
d'éveil au théâtre et c'est mélanie
poker qui va nous en dire plus bonjour
mélanie bonjour camille alors cette
nouvelle activité proposée dépasse le
simple cours de théâtre puisqu'il faut
savoir que le théâtre versailles et est
l'un des plus anciens de france il est
même le deuxième plus ancien après celui
de metz il était inaugurée en 1577 par
le roi louis saez et son épouse marie
antoinette
il se situe même à deux pas du château
royal pour en revenir à l'expérience du
théâtre
ce terrain est une expérience globale
les équipes de montans yves par mail un
chemin initiatique avec un cours
hebdomadaire
bien sûr mais aussi une initiation à la
technique écoutez les enfants vont
découvrir le théâtre à travers une
visite aussi à travers des rencontres
avec des techniciens costumier
machinistes metteur en scène et vont
également assister à des spectacles de
la saison pour voir en action
à quoi ressemble vraiment le théâtre
alors c'est qu'être ces spectacles
seront 4 il y a le médecin volant avec
les farces de molière les contes du chat
perché des célèbres contes de écrit par
michel aimé les rustres et lydie et
pourront eux aussi monter sur scène
c'est un peu le but des ateliers on va
dire aussi les hommes puisque notamment
il ya un cours hebdomadaire qui a lieu
tous les mercredis après midi il s'agit
bien là de montrer le fruit du travail
d'une année les cours de théâtre sont
dispensés par myriam où les hommes c'est
une ancienne institutrice en ch'ti
tutrice spécialisés et elle est
aujourd'hui actrice et comédienne alors
à quelle tranche d'âge sont destinés ces
ateliers
alors ça s'adresse aux enfants de 10 à
12 ans se sont laissés est mêlé sixième
et pour cet été ils ont dû prouver leur
envie de parts
si paix à travers une lettre de
motivation et marie nicolardot première
d'écouté de cette fois les raisons
le théâtre c'est un art vivant donc on
n'y va pas de façon passive et le but
était vraiment de créer une émulation
dès le départ voilà puisqu'il faut être
vraiment partie prenante dans un cours
de théâtre puisque le théâtre mobilisent
évidemment la voix mais aussi le corps
donc pour que les enfants sont impliqués
ou s'est dit qu'il fallait dès le début
donné donné un peu la note mais
malheureusement cette initiation est
déjà victime de son succès et oui 12
places étaient disponibles les
inscriptions se sont faites durant le
mois de septembre et jean du premier
cours le 21 septembre et s'était déjà 15
mais pas de panique il reste les
ateliers d'arts plastiques lors des
vacances scolaires est aussi assez
sympathique
il ya là un côté après chaque
représentation du mercredi après-midi
toutes les informations se trouvent sur
le site de l'établissement merci
beaucoup mélanie de nous avoir fait
découvrir ses ateliers on espère que
cela suscitera peut-être des vocations
théâtrale chez les plus jeunes